en carretillas tiradas por burros en
carros oa pie así decenas de palestinos
que vivían en el norte y en el este de
la franja de gaza- abandonaron sus casas
para buscar un refugio en las escuelas
de la onu algunos llevaron sus colchones
y otros sólo alcanzaron a salir con lo
que llevaban puesto
los bombardeos de israel contra la
franja de gaza en la noche del jueves
fueron tantos que muchas familias no
pudieron salir de sus casas y tuvieron
que esperar a la mañana para salvarse
casi no hubo ningún aviso ni nada
empezamos a gritar alá es grande
sentíamos como la casa se estremecía de
arriba a abajo no podíamos salir al lobo
la situación es muy difícil logramos a
la hasta que salió el sol hablar desde
el lunes el grupo hamas ha disparado
cerca de 1800 misiles contra israel y el
ejército israelí ha respondido
bombardeado gas pero esta vez los
militares no le advirtieron a los
civiles que iban a atacar como si lo
hicieron a principios de la semana
lo que para israel fue una operación
contra la red de túneles de hamás
terminó siendo una pesadilla para
cientos de palestinos salvo a una mujer
de 32 años asegura que los tanques y los
aviones israelíes bombardearon toda la
zona donde vivían
nos sentíamos como si estuviéramos en
una película de terror y era peor que la
película de terror lo que parecía un
destello entró en la casa y golpeó todo
no podíamos salir yo solo abrazaba a mis
dos hijas
aunque ha habido muertos de lado y lado
los habitantes de gaza han llevado la
peor parte y más después del ataque del
jueves el ministerio de salud de gaza
calcula que desde el lunes más de 100
civiles han muerto por los ataques
aéreos de israel una tercera parte de
ellos eran niños